he may be a long way from xinjiang now
but ibikit still has the scars
from Shackles on his legs handcuffs on
his arms from the time he spent at a
detention Camp imprisoned for
downloading WhatsApp is it difficult to
talk about what happened to you even now
ibicut says at times he was tortured to
the point of passing out he is Chinese
by birth but an ethnic Kazakh he fled
the country three years ago
I spent
uh
was forced to work in a clothing Factory
and cotton from xinjiang is still
finding its way to the British High
Street 20 of the world's cotton is grown
in xinjiang and higher percentages of it
are processed and and made into Fabric
and apparel now he's threatening to sue
the British government if it doesn't ban
imports from the region the UK know so
much about what's going on in the weaker
region they know just how pervasive
forced labor is there and how much it
pervades our supply chains now to vote
to not create this legislation or to
vote against such kinds of legislation
is tantamount to saying we approve of
forced labor products entering into our
borders
last year the U.S announced a total
import ban on Cotton products from
xinjiang but where they've strengthened
their laws the UK hasn't big companies
here have to show that they're avoiding
using slavery in their supply chains but
there's no penalty if they fail to do so
and it's not just campaign groups that
want Britain to be tough on China how
closely linked are we to slave labor I
think we're very closely linked we need
to be on the front of this actually
leading the way not as we've now become
dragging our heels behind the rest so we
need to make it much more difficult the
British government have condemned human
rights violations in xinjiang a
spokesperson said the UK is absolutely
committed to tackling the issue of
uyghur forced labor in Supply chains and
say they've taken decisive action over
the last year they say they've
introduced new guidance on the risks of
doing business in xinjiang as well as
enhanced export controls and have
committed to introduce Financial
penalties for organizations that don't
comply with modern slavery reporting
requirements
Beijing has always denied human rights
violations but China's been accused of
torture in concentration camps in
genocide in xinjiang what's your message
to the British government
um
foreign
foreign
talking to us could endanger his family
it's taken courage for him to speak out
now he wants the government here to send
a message to Ali Fortescue Sky News